The routes times and things like that that might be helpful in helping outreach to two members of the community sure
All right
Okay, let's move along to consent any items that any members of the council wish to pull
You what do you need?
Can I have a question on e okay anything else go ahead and ask your question
Okay
My question on knee is why or is there an ask for an additional?
13,000
15 15 even worse
All right, good evening
Yes, so with regards to e this is the amendment to the
Consulting Services agreement with city gate for the homelessness strategic plan
So we're at the what we're past the mid project briefing point. So we met with them
Kind of analyzed where we're going and there were some additional services that
We recommended that are outside of the scope of what originally was bidded the main things that would be included is
There's going to be an additional
Section where they come that's going to be on the 3rd of September and they're going to be
Presenting their findings to the public. So that wasn't originally included. They only had one more visit to go over the
The draft of the actual strategic plan when it was ready
So that's going to be an opportunity to get feedback from the council feedback from the public on the findings and then beyond that
some additional time is going to be built in for
One-on-ones or two two ones with the council members individually to try to
Take the findings and elaborate on those as the draft
Plan is brought forward. Okay, and how much was it originally?
75,000 what's budgeted?
So this amendment would change it to 90. So basically a
Padding of up to 15,000 more if any more
Items were sent in
So it's to get to get feedback
So in the presentations it'll be feedback. It'll be an additional visit for a study session
There's also some wanted
A little bit of a deep dive on some historical programs that we've had just to look at the effectiveness of those
And elaborate further on what was in the mid-project briefing
So so they're requesting an additional 15
They're not requesting an additional 15, but we're putting that as a placeholder
What was requested from them was around 8,800 or so
but
You know just in case there's some more back and forth we figured
Just have a little bit of a padding window there in case
You know they come for the initial
Draft
Presentation of the strategic plan when that comes forward later this fall probably
if there's any kind of
You know comments come back
An additional presentation. We just wanted to have that buffer there
I think I'd like to push that number down
Yeah, yeah, I don't think we need the 15. I think that they need to
I think even 75 is
A substantial amount to get make something happen
And they're asking for an additional 88 just for more conversation. They need to speak faster
Yeah, so maybe maybe we'll cap it at 10
Why don't we bring this item back next time and if you can provide
Details about exactly what they're asking for and why and maybe that will answer the questions because I think it's too vague right now
Okay, and just adding to that I would say if if
Yeah, why isn't it why wasn't it included in in the in their initial contract 70,000 right
In my mind some of the things you're saying I think that those are pretty standard for you know
Just the basic contract like presenting to us
once or twice or whatever that is so
Yeah, I just don't I mean the creep that we've been seeing on some of some of these
Want to make sure we we we put a hold on that. All right. Do I have a motion to approve
All I have a consent lane. Oh, you have other questions. I'm sorry. Oh, go ahead
Can I ask some questions and then might pull it out or there's almost eight o'clock you better hurry
You can do it. Um, okay. So on C
Is the great way villa? I just want to clarify who's who's in charge of C? That's the
um
Curtis. So this is canceling the agreement the 990,000 on the home
the affordable housing project
we're not
We're not deciding where that money goes or what else happens. We're just pulling that money out
No, so this was something that was brought back
back in
I believe it was late may early june. Um at that point we were trying to
Terminate it but put it towards something else repurpose the funds and that was kind of like let's put this on hold
Let's figure out
When or what that gap is for the affordable housing developer. So we went back to them
They essentially said the gap is a very large amount
So us replacing that 990 with something else from our
You know a different funding source within the city
We're into really gotten the project off the ground
Uh, so at that point it was decided well, let's go ahead and just terminate the agreement
And at a future council meeting it'll be brought forward to discuss potential uses for that
But right now we just want to de-obligate because we want to make sure to utilize those funds in a timely manner because they are
Um, you know starting to tick
Got it. Okay. And thank you Curtis. My other question was on j
um, it's uh
It's the first operating memorandum for reimbursement of public utility improvements. So I just wanted to understand
um
Why we're reimbursing and
What what this is about
Good evening mayor members of the council, uh, yeah, so on item j
This is related to the shops at harupa project
over off a mission and uh, pyrite
and uh during the process of the
construction of the improvements the city was
obligated to do the improvements along pyrite and mission and
during the process of
The developer doing the work on site
They were able to get things done
with a another contractor
Quicker than we could the city we had put the project out to bid
Along with the other improvements and it was going with the developers contractor that bid the project out completely
With prevailing wage and everything else. They were able to get it at a 50 savings compared to what we were able to get the bid at
Okay, so this is a
This is the reimbursement to the developer
For that those portions of the project. Okay. What's the what's the parameters of our
Reimbursement obligations and we're obligated to reimburse based on our agreement
Yeah, because the improvements that were done were the obligation of the city
Okay, and then they took it on is there a cap on the reimbursements that were
We're obligated to provide for
This is the extent that is the extent. Yeah, this is this is it. Okay
And then was this work that we're reimbursing them for was this
Were they required to pay?
prevailing wages
Absolutely. Yes. Okay, and then we we can track that we've tracked that we've all that information is is held
In our files. Yes, we do have a they did the proper bidding procedures
We have all the prevailing wage information as well. Yes. Okay, and then I know I know there's been a couple of
kind of different versions of
Us contributing to infrastructure development. Do we know the number of how much we've spent
um on infrastructure
Improvements if you will around that project or in and around
Well, we had a CIP project to do
improvements on mission and pyrite. I don't have that number right off the top of my hand here
But we can also get that to you as well, but there was improvements that we did as part of a CIP
got it. Okay, and is there any
pending
improvements that the developer is supposed to do or
At this point is there any any
Anything that they haven't done or that hasn't gotten done
There there is an item within the agreement of underground and utilities along mission
Um, but that's a long process that the developer will have to work through with with Southern California Edison
So they're they're responsible for undergrounding correct. Okay. Well, how long would that take?
And they're responsible for full undergrounding correct is it like
Do we have a plan for that? I could know the developer will have to prepare the plan
And then they'll work with Edison
To get those plans approved then Edison will have to develop their own plans for their circuitry
To get those the everything approved then then they will hire a contractor
The developer will hire a contractor to put the conduits in and then Edison will have to come through and pull all the conductors through
Steve does that include so on and every time I get off pyrite as my favorite exit to get off on
Um
I get off on pyrite and then i'm on mission
There's a there's like a poll in that corner pyrite and mission that that seems like it's
very kind of outside does that include that poll
Would you be talking about the north east or the northwest the north east is where the development is the northwest is where it's a vacant feel
We're a future development. Yes. That one the northwest one. Yeah
uh
I can't speak for Edison because the
When we talk about undergrounding poles, we think it's a it's a drop of three poles and they say well
No, you have to add one on either side and all that stuff
I couldn't tell you so they decide when the project start or when the project gets pitched or well Edison would
When the design starts for the undergrounding
They would have to coordinate with Edison and Edison would then explain all right well. You're going to cut these three poles out
That are in on the frontage of your property because that's what we require the frontage would have to be underground anything beyond that limit
It doesn't have to be underground it, but Edison may come back and say well that poll supports that poll
And therefore by taking that poll out
Just making something up at the northeast corner by taking that poll out
Well, then you'll have to add another poll on the other side
right so the
Edison is the the driver of what polls come out
The developers required to take the polls out in front of the property
Okay, and on the reimbursement is there any
benefit or
any way we can
Push or invite the developer to get moving on that undergrounding
We can definitely ask them to get moving on that
Can we wait on on this reimbursement until until they submit a plan for example
Well the development agreement or the agreement that we're talking about here
Doesn't specify the time of these this reimbursement. Yeah
It specifies that these improvements need to be done
As far as the undergrounding there is a time period once the plans have been approved by Edison
Once they're approved by Edison, correct
Okay, is there can we set up time on on the actual undergrounding like say hey you need to do this
within the next x amount of years or whatever
I think that that would require
Opening the agreement back up and and I'm sorry
Of course, I don't think you can know because of the fact that medicine control got it
If we control the plan you could
But since Edison does it we want to be able to do that
Okay, so we were reimbursement for this, but really there's no way to hold them to actually doing the undergrounding in any
Near future. Oh, they will be required to do the undergrounding, but every here we
The time in which they do it
Begins when Edison says here are the plans to go forward. Also Edison is the driver
Okay, got it
Okay, I understand okay
Is that clarified? Yeah, okay. Do we have a motion to approve the consent calendar with
minus e
And minus i move to approve
Second
Second all in favor aye opposed abstentions motion carries five zero
Item 15 approval of the minutes from july 16th 2026 the regular meeting any of my colleagues have any comments or questions or modifications